bonjour vous regardez l'entretien de
France 24 nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
les bureaux du gouvernement à Kiev avec
le vice premier ministre de l'Ukraine
Mireille qui est aussi ministre de la
transformation numérique je voudrais
commencer par une question sur cette
transformation numérique est-ce qu'elle
a pu continuer sous des conditions de
guerre ou est-ce que vous avez dû
transformer en quelque sorte votre
ministère
nous avions quatre tâches principales
dématérialiser tous les services publics
connectés 95% de la population à
Internet développer l'économie des
technologies de l'effet l'information
l'économie numérique et enseigner aux
gens des compétences informatiques et
pourtant la guerre a surgit nous avons
repositionné tous ces objectifs dans un
effort de guerre désormais nous
fournissons des services liés à la
guerre comme des aides l'enregistrement
des dommages à la propriété nous
reconnectons les territoires
anciennement occupés à Internet nous
avons installé Starlink le même en
Ukraine
en ce qui concerne l'économie des
technologies de l'information nous
sommes en train de créer une sorte de
blocus numérique contre la Fédération de
Russie en travaillant avec des sociétés
de technologie du monde entier pour les
inciter à quitter la Russie et souvent
cela se traduit par la délocalisation de
leurs activités en Ukraine vous venez
d'évoquer Starling qu'est-ce qu'il est
vrai que vous avez juste écrit un tweet
à Elon Musk en disant s'il vous plaît
donnez-nous Starlink et il a répondu
d'accord pouvez-vous me dire comment ça
comme souvent avec les tweets il y a une
histoire plus longue derrière nous
étions en contact depuis longtemps avec
Space X et ces dernières années nous
avons tout fait pour les convaincre de
commencer à travailler en Ukraine
c'est vrai qu'après ce tweet le
processus de mise en service de Starlink
en Ukraine c'est accéléré
quelles applications ont été créées par
votre ministère ou sous l'impulsion de
votre ministère pendant la guerre on
pense particulièrement à evoroc par
exemple qui permet aux gens de signaler
la présence de force
[Musique]
à notre application dia sur laquelle
elles utilisateurs sont vérifiés nous
avons créé un chatbot qui travaille avec
l'application de manière à vérifier que
les utilisateurs sont authentiques et ça
permet aux gens d'envoyer des
informations à propos de mouvements de
l'armée russe et de la concentration de
leur force
là où il y a où il y aurait des traîtres
n'importe quelle information qui peut
aider notre armée grâce à cela nous
obtenons au de l'information de qualité
que nous trions et que nous redirigeons
vers les services compétents
l'utilisent vraiment combien par exemple
justement sur les quatre ou cinq
derniers mois parce que nous l'avons
créé pendant le premier mois de la
guerre nous avons su plus de 30
000 messages c'est-à-dire des photos des
vidéos et descriptions détaillées donc
il y a beaucoup d'informations
comment les gens peuvent-ils être
certain qu'ils ne seront pas retrouvés
ou qu'ils n'auront pas de problème il y
a beaucoup d'instructions pour les
Ukrainiens qui utilisent le bot ils
doivent seulement envoyer des
informations s'ils sont sûrs que rien ne
va leur arriver ils doivent supprimer
toutes les données une fois qu'elles ont
été envoyées ils doivent s'assurer que
personne ne peut les voir quand ils les
envoient donc il y a tout un champ de
recommandation que nous avons établi
pour s'assurer que les gens fassent
attention
je voudrais encore vous poser une
question sur l'application dia on peut
voir le logo là sur le mur c'était
vraiment votre service fin au ministère
avant que le début de la guerre ça
permet aux Ukrainiens d'avoir leur
passeport ou leur permis de conduire
tout leur document dématérialisés je ne
suis pas sûr que ça existe dans un autre
pays mais n'y a-t-il pas un risque de
piratage d'autant plus que le contexte
place le créneau encore plus sous le
coup de ce genre de menaces
pour nous la guerre est devenue une
cyberguère à dès l'instant où nous avons
créé ce ministère et créer l'application
diables il y a eu des attaques dès le
début et donc nous avons bâti des
architectures de manière à sauver des
données afin qu'il n'y ait aucun risque
pour les utilisateurs authentifiés et
donc nous n'avons eu aucune fuite de
données et pendant la guerre loin de
nous arrêter de travailler nous avons
continué à faire face aux problèmes et
nous avons déployé des nouveaux services
il faut savoir que notre architecture
est sécurisé parce que nous nous
procédons aussi à des attaques dans le
cyberespace il y a une vraie guerre qui
se déroule mais ça ne nous empêche pas
de fournir des nouveaux services les
données sont sécurisées l'architecture
est sûre et maintenant nous avons non
seulement dia les services fiscaux et
les pensions de retraite qui sont aussi
numérisées
ont déclaré que tout agression de grand
ampleur de la part de la Russie
s'accompagnerait nécessairement de
cyberattaques massives j'ai cru
comprendre que ça n'a pas vraiment été
le cas pourquoi
la guerre il y a eu des grosses attaques
en décembre en janvier et en février
c'était vraiment des attaques sans
précédentes mais nous avons réussi à
nous défendre tout a changé après
l'invasion physique de l'Ukraine parce
que là nous avons commencé à attaquer
nous-mêmes et quand nous avons commencé
à faire des dégâts sur l'infrastructure
numérique de la Russie ils ont décidé de
rediriger toutes leurs ressources vers
la défense intérieure c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous développons
maintenant notre cyberdéfense nous
attaquons et déployons de nouveaux
services
pouvez-vous en dire plus sur les
attaques que vous avez lancées contre la
Russie nous avons créé un projet
intitulé Haïti à ami qui rassemble des
centaines de sociétés et des milliers de
volontaires
il y a vraiment une guerre à grande
échelle qui se déroule avec des
opérations des objectifs à tactiques et
stratégiques
je sais que votre ministère a fait
beaucoup en ce qui concerne les drones
acquérir des drones et former les gens
pour les piloter alors pourquoi est-ce
le ministère de la transformation
numérique et pas le ministère de la
Défense qui a l'initiative dans ce
domaine
c'est un projet conjoint entre notre
ministère et l'armée la technologie est
une composante essentielle des drones je
parle d'intelligence artificielle de
vision par ordinateur et de bien
d'autres outils de plus le secteur des
drones se développe rapidement et
concerne la technologie de défense je
veux dire par là que toute une nouvelle
industrie est en train de naître c'est
pour ça que nous avons créé un projet
conjoint nous avons calculé les besoins
en termes de drone de reconnaissance et
de drone d'attaque sur la ligne de front
et maintenant le levons des fonds
partout dans le monde pour acheter des
drones et signer des contrats nous
formons des gens pour l'utilisation des
drones nous réparons des drones et donc
nous avons monté ce projet conjointement
était
quel est le rôle de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les drones en ce qui
concerne la reconnaissance d'objets il y
a déjà un grand nombre de sociétés qui
utilisent l'intelligence artificielle
dans le but d'identifier précisément ce
qui peut être un tank ou un autre type
d'armement ou pour localiser un objet
spécifique dans les bois par exemple ça
aide au moment de la prise de décision
vous utilisez aussi l'intelligence
artificielle pour la reconnaissance
faciale n'est-ce pas pouvez-vous me dire
quelle technologie est utilisée en
Ukraine et à quelle échelle nous
utilisons l'intelligence artificielle
pour la reconnaissance faciale il y a
plusieurs usages quand des photos de
soldats russes morts apparaissent ça
nous permet de retrouver leur profil sur
les réseaux sociaux les coordonnées de
leurs proches et donc de les informer du
décès afin qu'ils viennent récupérer les
corps c'est ce qui se passe généralement
quand on peut identifier la personne
l'intelligence artificielle est
aujourd'hui utilisée dans des situations
diverses par exemple nous avons un
service qui nous permet de reconnaître
des objets en mouvement et de déterminer
s'il s'agit d'un objet militaire afin le
cas échéant de l'entrée dans le système
qui enregistre ces données ou que vous
regardiez aujourd'hui l'IA est utilisé
est-ce que vous avez utilisé cette
technologie pour reconnaître les soldats
russes qui ont été tués et prévenir leur
famille nous avons eu des centaines de
communication avec les familles de
soldats russes morts sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans 80% des cas il nous
répondent qu'ils étaient des héros
qu'ils ont fait ce qu'il fallait ils
nous disent aussi qu'ils vont eux-mêmes
venir en Ukraine et qui vont nous tuer
mais quelle technologie est utilisée
plutôt pendant la guerre la société
clairview a dit qu'elle vous avait
fourni son application y a-t-il des gens
en Ukraine qu'il utilise ou bien il
s'agit plutôt d'autres applications de
reconnaissance faciale nous utilisons
des solutions variées je ne peux pas
divulguer en public le nom des marques
en particulier mais il y a des solutions
qui ont été utilisé mais quand cette
société clairview vous a fourni cette
technologie vous vous en êtes très
publiquement félicité et maintenant vous
dites que vous ne voulez pas dévoiler
quelle technologie et spécifiquement
utilisée pour la reconnaissance faciale
pourquoi un non
nous avons certains accords avec
différentes sociétés selon lesquelles
nous pouvons annoncer que nous avons
commencé à travailler ensemble c'est le
cas avec certaines d'entre elles pas
toutes mais disons des choses comme ça
dans les situations où ces technologies
sont effectivement utilisées c'est mieux
de ne pas l’annoncer publiquement
que se passe-t-il si la technologie de
reconnaissance faciale fait une erreur
et vous envoyez un message au mauvaise
personne par exemple et d'ailleurs
l'utiliser vous seulement dans le cas de
soldats russmau ou dans d'autres
contextes aussi
il y a eu des cas où nous l'avons
utilisé pour trouver des pilleurs à bout
de chats et dans d'autres endroits dans
les régions de Kev et tennis quand le
système reconnaît un visage il vous
donne un ratio de probabilité
70-8095% de ressemblance et il y a bien
sûr d'autres outils pour recouper les
informations en grande partie les
réseaux sociaux on peut vérifier par
exemple si c'est un soldat et d'autres
informations qui peuvent nous permettre
de confirmer son identité
il y a des moments où nous vérifions
mais nous ne pouvons pas être sûr que
l'information est confirmée et dans ce
cas cela nécessite plus de travail et
les systèmes de support doivent
fonctionner
y a-t-il eu des cas d'erreurs
d'identification
nous n'avons pas eu de cas d'erreurs
d'identification ou des cas où nous
sommes certains qu'il y a eu une erreur
cela dit il y a un cas où des
volontaires nous ont contactés avec une
demande d'identification d'une personne
qui était à l'hôpital et qui avait perdu
la mémoire
nous l'avons identifié et il s'est avéré
qu'il s'agissait d'un soldat russe qui
essayait juste de tromper son monde en
prétendant qu'il avait perdu la mémoire
vraiment oui vraiment on a eu un cas
comme ça
et après la personne a été faite
prisonnière
je ne sais pas où il est mais je pense
qu'il est là où il mérite d'être
une question plus générale sur
l'informatique dans cette guerre le
crâne est un pays réputé pour ses
spécialistes en la matière mais c'est
aussi le cas la Russie
l'Ukraine a-t-elle un avantage ou non
nous avons clairement un avantage parce
que nous avons le soutien de tout le
monde civilisé des pays qui ont des
secteurs technologiques développés nous
avons des transferts de technologie nous
communiquons des sociétés viennent
travailler en Ukraine des sociétés de
technologie déménage en Ukraine donc il
y a du soutien et de la Coopération
alors qu'en Russie c'est le contraire
les sociétés de technologie de
l'information et les spécialistes
quittent la Russie parce que vous ne
pouvez pas évoluer en tant qu'ingénieur
dans ce secteur en vivant en dictature
ce n'est pas possible sans liberté sans
les services basiques pour les créatifs
quand MasterCard Paypal ou autre ne
fonctionne pas donc de manière
stratégique nous nous entendons à ce
qu'il y ait encore plus de développement
dans ce secteur les technologies de
l'information c'est actuellement le seul
secteur en croissance en Ukraine pendant
la guerre il dégage des revenus en
augmentation alors que la Russie peut
s'attendre à une chute parce que les
sociétés les ingénieurs s'en vont vous
ne pouvez pas créer un produit tech avec
une valeur ajoutée significative dans
les conditions dans lesquelles il se
trouve actuellement et qui sont le
résultat de leurs décisions d'attaquer
l'Ukraine
merci
aujourd'hui et merci à vous d'avoir
regardé l'actualité continue sur France
[Musique]